people have forgotten the humanity in
others especially online totally right
so i love love what you're saying you
know
like this essence of bringing love to
the table even if you don't have
something in common with somebody and
talking it out and just listening
understanding where they're coming from
you don't have to believe the same
things but like i can love you
and disagree and i can listen it's like
this is how you bring love to the table
it's so easy to get trapped in to
curating your social media platform to
all of your likes
um and i don't mean like says in what
you're liking pictures but your
interests because soon as there's
opposition in your viewpoint there's
like
there's a breach
100 and you're uncomfortable now because
it doesn't follow the the flow of your
timeline and it's like okay
report unfollow block don't want to see
that and what that does is reinforce
beliefs
that this is the right way without
having a conversation with the other
side or seeing what the other side is
doing to like you said to get the common
ground if we have tunnel vision in only
one way we're so far from the middle
ground that we're unaware of what middle
ground is i just had such a compelling
conversation with my friends christina
and cash if you clicked on this video or
you clicked on this podcast to listen to
you probably know who they are i have
been friends with christina for many
years now and i have loved getting to
know cash as well christina is such a
humble person she's so strong and has
gone through a lot in regards to this
topic of cancer culture and so that's
why i'm so excited to sit down with them
and have this conversation because their
dynamic and what they both bring to the
table on the topic is so fascinating and
like just really so much that we can
learn from it the growth mindset that
cash has and just like the strength that
christina brings to the table of all
she's gone through i think is like a
wonderful topic to discuss especially
when it comes to
our own personal lives not just lives
online as you know not many people are
going to be
having that same experience but your
personal life as well and how we can
grow from
the mindset that what other people think
about us really matters versus that it
doesn't and that you can create your
reality within your mind you can live in
a way that
brings yourself to a place of having
growth and joy no matter whether
everyone likes you or not so i think
that this is a wonderful topic i love
this conversation there's so much to
talk about honestly we could have gone
on and on and on and i love the
specifics that we get into on things
that she's gone through as well as just
the overall arching theme of what we can
learn from such a topic
we also talk about their relationship
and their
dynamic together and there's just so
much more anyways without further ado
let's get into this conversation i hope
you enjoy it
all right we are on thank you guys so
much for being here it has been so nice
getting to see you and getting to spend
time with you and andrew honestly my
heart is so happy and we loved waking up
to your kids this morning it was just
wonderful yeah it's been such an amazing
time just being here already kids waking
us up in the morning getting to connect
with them and just getting to experience
like what it was like to be a child and
that energy they put out you know very
much well receptive and received so well
they love hanging out with you guys
they're so happy you're here they're
actually sad you're only here for a
couple days and i told sandy not to go
over in the morning i'm like don't go
over we don't know if they're sleeping
still but he still went when i wasn't
looking yeah we're coming back and he we
loved it
yeah i was going to say sandy he he's a
character all you all your kids are
special but you know sandy and elvis
definitely got a good connection with
them he came by this morning and just
gave us a little morning check to see
what we're doing i'm like hey yeah
we're just in
bed nothing going on
but that was fun this morning i got a
chance to play basketball with them and
connect with them play games they're so
good with kids okay well firstly let's
just get into a little bit about your
land and the projects you're working on
and your garden is like amazing it's
totally blown me away how quickly you've
done your garden please explain how do
you do it what are you up to thank you
well we moved to hawaii a year ago and
um that was in the long-term plans
um for some of my long-term followers
they might know that i ran roughly
organic for 11 years so i do have a
background in growing things organic
produce organic distribution
um and i put together a plan for me to
have my own organic
like kitchen garden but i wanted it to
be
my perfect garden and so it took me six
months to
manifest to go from the manifestation
part of it and creating the plans versus
making it an actual garden so we had to
find the right crew to assist us in
bringing this to life because when you
have the amount of land that we're on
you have so much room to work with and
you have to find that true intention for
specific areas especially if you want to
have them zoned for like produce or your
citrus and all those you want the right
wood the right compost soil you want the
right seeds and so
once you get into the sourcing and then
you figure out your design then you can
get your hands dirty but the planning
part took 90 percent of the energy
executing it probably took 10 percent
that is seriously amazing and it's so
inspiring we have those goals like
andrew and i we have like goals to
become
as sustainable as we can within like
five to seven years but it's a little
bit slower process for us for sure
i
that's i think it's just beautiful to be
able to
encourage people to grow their own food
and to be able to do it yourself i mean
that's that's the lifestyle we want to
live right and so for me getting to grow
my own food and eat it is just
it's the ultimate gift right there's
there's just no greater feeling and i
know you're doing so great over here
like i've seen what you're doing and i'm
just like i love it oh totally it's not
there's nothing better than like food
sustainability picking your own food
from your land
i'm just like blown away by your garden
it was so beautiful as long as i've
known christina this is something she's
talked about
constantly and has been part of her
passion
and she's really held on to that vision
through obstacles and overcoming a lot
of different situations and just to
maintain it and then bring it to reality
like you know i know you're proud of the
garden that you created because this
this is like your dream so well it's not
just the garden we're we're on nine
acres right now trying to restore it the
garden is just one part but eventually i
would
we are working towards restoring this
fruit orchard and i'm turning into an
exotic fruit orchard so uh we still have
a long ways to go
it's amazing what are you gonna plant
what's like your most like top five
favorite fruits you for sure we'll be
planting lots of jackfruit and
keep going
honestly it's more than five it's like
every exotic fruit you can think of
we'll be doing camitos mango
we'll do all types of sapotes it's
really nice we're gonna be my goal is to
specialize in the exotic fruits to
contribute to the community that would
be amazing that's so so cool okay well
let's talk a little bit about like your
relationship story i don't know i don't
know your full relationship story i'd
like to get a little bit more details
like how you guys came to be the way you
are
yeah so that's a great question i
actually love this question because
christina and i
we always go back and forth on the story
but at the end of the day it is very
insightful and just funny
to like hear someone's story about how
love came because it doesn't always have
to fit a certain narrative or a certain
image
and
when christina came into my life i was
completely unaware of the vegan
lifestyle i only knew one person who was
vegan and he was vegan for about 11
years and i was just like man how could
you do this like you're just eating just
veggies and produce and i was always
just messing with them and then
christina comes into my life and she's
just like opening me up to so many new
possibilities of like really living so
that was awesome but to answer your
question
we met at a social gathering where
christina was designated to prepare food
i was chefing at a a
a gathering let's call it that i was
chefing at a house party
and um
cash was the only person in the kitchen
while everybody was like in the living
room oh yeah like you know doing
appetizers and things and
i was in the kitchen trying to keep my
coolness right he was sitting on the
counter and just looking at his phone
and i'm sitting here chopping i'm like
why is this guy like in here with me so
i offered him
like i took a piece of a cherry tomato
and i put in some kales like do you want
cow and some cherry tomatoes to snack on
and he just looked up at me and he was
like he didn't even say no he didn't
there was no
word that came out and then he just went
back to his phone and i'm sitting there
like
okay
unfortunately that was that was our
first encounter unfortunately to my
defense i wasn't really passionate about
tomatoes never have been
and kale was just the noodles oh my gosh
that i'm getting introduced to so i was
very
beginner at understanding this lifestyle
but what ended up happening is um we
were connected through a similar group
of friends in houston and i was very
busy at the time running my co-op and
you know i think i was just finishing my
book tour i was like halfway through it
and um
i just gotten back from bali and i was
going through that really crazy period
of my life where my co-op had just been
forced to close
i was going through every major life
crisis i could possibly going through at
one point in time from like
losing some of my best friends to people
stealing money from me to
uh having so much portrayal going on it
was just like everything came crashing
down and the universe was like
i'm just gonna steer you this way you're
not gonna like it but i promise things
will be okay in the long run and
it's interesting because once you're you
know really high for a period of time
everybody wants to be your friend the
second you kind of lose it all everybody
starts walking out of your life
and
i felt really alone at the time but i
just remember one day getting a random
text from cash and he's like hey i hear
you're having a really hard time sounds
like you could use a real friend in your
life like someone who stays because
that's actually really sad that that has
been your experience like when [ __ ] hits
the fan
all your friends are going to leave you
know because that's not really
everyone's experience but that was your
experience so when you you know cash
comes into the picture like what a
meaningful important yes and it showed
me that those weren't real friends right
and um
and i was like i i was so numb at the
time i think i was just going through so
much i was like oh thank you that's
sweet you know
and then he's like what are you doing
tomorrow i was like going to yoga right
i was like i had just gotten back in
town from bali and next thing i know he
shows up at my yoga class never taken a
yoga class before walks in
to speak all like
cool
got the swag movement going on he's like
i'm gonna go to yoga the yoga studio had
like this new member or like visitor
membership like trial for 30 days or
something so i was like okay
you know opportunity try yoga christina
i mean that's not a bad situation to be
in
your open-mindedness
we're shaking the whole time he was
shaking
and uh i just remember it was our first
time ever hanging out and we took a
picture after and i remember he told me
he's like i just got my first l
and i was like what does that mean he
goes my first loss
and i was like oh
okay
and then like you could have won or
something
i was saying that isn't like i had
expectations to like really thrive
through this yoga class because i'm like
weightlifting playing basketball doing
all this stuff i'm saying i'm in fit you
know coming from this place of ego and
then all these other people in the class
are just going through these poses and
just exceeding expectations and my arms
were just struggling it was a heated
room so it's just something i wasn't
used to but uh i'm glad i had the
opportunity to like you know experience
that with christina and we laughed about
it and we still laugh about it today so
and it's a vulnerable moment like you're
choosing to be like you know i'm gonna
pursue this in an uncharted territory
expecting it to go well and then it
doesn't
you get humbled real quick but in a way
we were both in a very raw position and
like i was just stripped raw from so
much going on in my life and you're like
all right i should have brought on this
moment
naturally we ended up being yoga buddies
and we would do yoga three four times a
week sometimes every day and we were
friends for a year and a half before
um we decided to start dating yeah so
that's pretty much the foundation of how
we even had the opportunity to see like
is this something more than what we're
doing currently because there was a lot
of healing in that year and a half that
needed to take place because
christina was going through moments of
like self-awareness of understanding how
to set healthy boundaries and i was
trying to highlight that for her to let
her know like hey it's okay to be
stirring with someone who's overstepping
the respect that you are deserved and
should be given and so i was really
trying to communicate that on her behalf
to give her that strength and say hey it
is okay to be stern with
your beliefs and your truth of how you
should be respected and handled and
i feel like when she realized my
intentions was to help her heal
there was a moment where like this could
be more and we just kept hanging out and
this lo and behold i'm the one who
suggested
that we should date because it felt like
we were dating and we were hanging out
every day and he you know became my
closest friend in houston and i was like
i think it would be wonderful if we
dated we're very well balanced this
isn't a lustful thing this is
this is a core rooted friendship
and
he said no
oh man
he was like cash is very emotionally
emotional he's got some serious
emotional intelligence and i just
remember he looked at me and he was like
in order for you and me to meet you have
to have more space in your life for me
and i was like what are you talking
about i give you all i actually remember
that i remember you texting me about
this and i was like
yeah i remember it and i'm like i'm like
actually that's amazing like that like
to speak up like that i remember feeling
that way exactly he was like you need to
get rid of this person this person this
person he like listed them out and he's
like all these people are taking
advantage of you and you're allowing it
they're energy vampires he's like i
don't understand how you're ever going
to have emotional space for me
if you're like letting this suck you dry
and so
yeah it was
to me i just saw it as it and it was
unfortunate because i was like someone
as beautiful as her
inside and out
has all this potential to share with the
world yet there's people who just take
advantage of her because like
christina's a very nice kind-hearted
person and i was just i saw it as if
they're constantly putting and
projecting
damaging energy onto her and she has to
express that with me constantly we'll
never have room to talk about us it
would just be how do we heal these
broken friendships that aren't really
true friendships and i was just really
trying to like make her see like no no
we have to protect our space that we're
trying to build because that's where
growth in our relationship growth and
potential ideas of like family and all
these things there's a sacred space for
me and i just wanted to like highlight
and say like this is important to me
that's actually like really healthy and
maybe partly because you didn't have
many experiences with friends that were
really true friends to express honesty
and openness
and have like maybe like a healthy
emotional balance and intellect like the
fact that you like brought that to light
was probably like really helpful for not
only your relationship but like for your
own life yes it was
so i did it and i i remember texting you
throughout this whole time because it
was really challenging because i felt
like i
i don't know it was very hard for me to
learn what boundaries were that's been
one of my greatest life
struggles and journeys has been
understanding proper boundaries with
people and so as soon as i i don't want
to say got rid of these people in my
life but i knew where to place them so
that i felt safe and protected and i
wasn't allowing them to hurt me
you know two three months passed and i
came back to cash i was like all right
i've done this i feel like i'm ready
let's give this a try
yeah and again he was like no
you're not ready yet and i don't what
was the second reason why i forget it
was it was a new scenario that came back
up and it was
heavier and i don't know if you want to
elaborate about it well give the general
because i'm trying to remember what it
was i think at this point in time there
was there were i think this was like the
onslaught of like the fallout from the
co-op
where
oh yeah yeah okay
basically some other things had had
reared and
he asked me again
i need to do x y z and this means like
you need to get and i also want to say
this because
when the business is starting to close
it's not just like okay today's the end
and then we move on so when she says
like she went to bali
and to like heal and stuff
the the business of that she had at that
magnitude the scale of it like it was
some time before it fully closed and so
as she's healing through
setting healthy boundaries from just
friends
here comes the business bringing
something new on the table like okay
deal with this now and it was just as
big as like some of these damaged
relationships with friends and we had to
work through that and there was like
some drama and i i think more than
anything
cash
really wanted me to be able
to move through these things
without allowing them to totally just
destroy me so that he always had to be
the one picking me back up that's so
healthy and like rare i think and
it was very difficult for both of us
because i was working through my
abandonment issues i was like all right
here he is preparing to like just drop
me i don't want her right
so i was like but i but in my heart i
knew i had to do it so you know
i
mustered everything i had and i pulled
myself together and
um i think
her like one of the hurricanes hit right
after that and then i got really into
like community work and helping houston
recover from a hurricane and then it was
harvey yeah a couple months after that i
just remember we came back to the table
and i asked one final time i was like
are like i i don't understand i was like
you're spending all this time with me
it's like
we're technically dating but you won't
you won't date me and you know i was
like this is it and then finally again
he was like no
he's like but this time this is about
me
but this is good i think that a lot of
people need to hear this this time it
was about me because it was more so like
you've done your work
and i've assisted you in guiding you
through that but i had came out of a
relationship like a year before knowing
christina or
i'm not really sure how the time matches
up but i know i haven't i didn't finish
healing because i found out that the
person i was pursuing and dating we've
invested all this time and energy i
found out through social media that she
was messing around with someone else so
like it kind of caught me off guard and
by surprise so
christina's asking me to trust her and
it's
i'm wanting to
but emotionally i wasn't ready to trust
anyone right um and that's why the third
time was no but we still overcame these
hurdles and i don't know how we have so
much patience with each other to like go
through these things but look how far
it's gotten us now yes
cash and i have
very solid communication right now even
with scenarios that might for most
people be considered extremely painful
i think it's just his energy he carries
everything with such balance and
calmness like we can talk about
difficult things and just be very
practical about it and it's um it's very
nice and that's actually why like the
main reason why i want to have this
conversation with not just you but you
as well on the topic of cancel culture
like because there's like different ways
to handle and receive energies and what
you're going through and so
the ways that like you guys have
essentially helped each other through
your hardships and how you've helped her
through every time you've been quote
unquote called out cancelled
and just the different perspectives you
can have within an experience i think
it's like pivotal and it's going to be
such a great conversation to segue into
so we should just get into that then
yeah and thanks for sharing your story i
think that that is like a beautiful
story honestly and like really rare
because a lot of times i think
relationships like kind of feed off of
your suffering like you find each other
because you're suffering this can be
like really like partner
romantic relationships or even
friendship relationships where you might
be struggling with something and then
you find yourselves feeding off each
other through your negativity and the
the hardships and it's good to be like
there for each other but there's a
difference between helping lift one
another up as opposed to just like
bringing each other down right and i
think like something a lot of people
have learned is that if your friendship
if you find yourself in your friendship
always talking negatively
made about your own experiences but
especially if it's about others then you
realize that like you're getting this
like false sense of like a security and
a friendship like you think you're
having a genuine friendship when really
insurance falls reassurance yeah like
you think and then the moment that
something happens like any with any kind
of effect like it all falls apart
because there was no genuine foundation
of a friendship because you only just
fed off each other because if you think
it's like a false connection when you're
like talking about other people and just
like yeah anyways it's true i think
people enter into relationships any kind
of relationship friendships romantic
relationships thinking this other person
is going to save me or they will be
there for me and i will use them as a
crutch in a way very few people enter
into relationship thinking
i need to be 100 so i can give this
person yeah 100 right yeah and then and
then when you are going through
something you already have that
foundation totally so amazing right yes
oh that's such a good topic i mean that
could be like a whole episode
but okay let's talk about cancel culture
this is what we're really here for
i'm ready we're ready for this and
before we like get into the nitty-gritty
i kind of wanted to like
talk about what cancel culture really
means because i think there's like
multiple ways to describe it and define
it and people might be looking at it in
different ways
because like if we're going to get into
this and and talk about all the ways
that you've been cancelled and how many
times you've been called out for
something because honestly it astonishes
me like i like i look at you andrew and
i talked about this he's like literally
i don't understand like all she ever
shares is positivity love and kindness
like how how is she getting torn down so
much like for the most like random
things it feels that's how it feels and
just it's almost it's happened so much
that it almost feels like comical at
this point like huh yeah again we're
still doing this we're still doing this
so i think that if we can like define it
on what it really means to like you guys
and me like that'll help shape the
conversation guy that we can like get
into like what you're really um
what you've gone through
so for me i kind of wrote down what i
think like i think cancel culture which
is i think can also be called call out
culture
call out culture i think is a better way
to truly define it because most of the
time when someone's like canceled
their whole life isn't actually
destroyed it does happen but i think
most of the time they can still continue
on with their career but generally it's
call out culture where you might get
this mob mentality for a period of time
either short or long
and then eventually everyone moves on
and picks on someone else that's kind of
what it feels like so call out culture i
think is like
more accurate i'm a term but it's a form
of boycotting or shunning an individual
often a celebrity for doing something
questionable or controversial or
something that some people consider
downright wrong enough to where they
think that their business should be
destroyed
that they often and they often encourage
others to not support the person their
product or company
socially and financially like that's
like it's kind of like their punishment
for what they did wrong you know
um and there's a collective attempt to
harm the reputation the person's
reputation and social presence and
sometimes even the livelihood for
violating a particular ideological
standard and the notion of canceling
someone has been around for like a long
time but it seems lately social media
has bolstered this like mom mentality of
like an unaccountable mob rule that
punishes the said like guilty person for
like the moral
violations yeah but what do you guys say
like do you think that's accurate
description or how else would you
describe it super accurate
it's it's 100 active spot on
well i wrote it down so that's why i
said it so perfect
just from what i've seen from
a lot of just either athletes
celebrities i mean there's current
people who's getting cancer right now so
there's like you said there's something
questionable about your comments
action choices uh sometimes it could
even lead to beliefs
and
i feel like media and how social media
is currently
if
if the call-out culture gets i actually
like how you position that if the
call-out culture gets enough momentum
behind
these accusations
no one else needs to validate whether
it's true or not yes it's just like this
compounding effect kind of like a
snowball effect coming down the mountain
just bills bills bills and no one stops
to say how do we get here
what is it about this person that we
just are going to jump to conclusions
and
where's your sources yeah is this even
true yeah because if enough people say
it then it must be true yeah it's kind
of like a general rule that's
unfortunate because there's a lot of
good people out here that have
like genuine hearts and for the world
and just people in general and
we're so quick to write someone off
because of assumptions yes so i'll build
on that um i've been
i've been
i don't want to say accused but i've
been
called out
for some really crazy and hurtful things
um
some questionable absolutely
but i will say that every single
one of these ripple effects started with
one person
who put out either a youtube video or a
post just totally bashing or shaming me
and it just started with one person's
opinion
and then it always amazes me how so many
people see it
assume it to be true ride the train and
before you know it the next morning
there's 60 youtube videos about you all
like building upon each other's
assumptions
no one's even spoken to you no one even
knows the truth and then that's not
interesting no it's not but it's um it's
it's how you destroy someone's integrity
like not it's how you destroy someone
essentially but it's also it gives other
people attention
it gives them
importance to a certain degree but
it
it's just interesting because that's how
every single one of these situations has
started that's really interesting
because i've had a couple times where
there's been like a call out for me as
well and it i don't know actually i
guess it did kind of now a couple times
one of the times it might have been like
a post i did that was like not well
liked by a lot of people and then and
then peop then people made videos about
it type of thing yeah um
and it kind of just got momentum based
on something i've said or done and then
another time might just just came out of
nowhere out of you know things like that
it can just come out of nowhere or it
could be something that you've said and
has a big reaction because it may i
actually was going to ask you i was like
once we get into this i mean there's
more i wanted to say before we got into
this but i was thinking what exactly is
like the first time that you've been so
called called out and i may be wrong the
first time i remember about you
would be like um when you painted your
whole body black did like an artistic
photo shoot
and did this like body art all over like
colorful body art and so that was like
maybe a reaction from like a post you
did
right actually the first time i
experienced cancer culture was uh
2014-ish or like
and it was for
it was for staying silent on something
that i had no business in
really um and that i not i did not want
to take business in and somebody got
upset with me for not standing up for
them
and
i mean
they came after me hard for it and that
was the first time
then i would say the second time was the
body painting
but what was interesting about it is it
was a puerto rican artist and we were in
a studio with
multiple cultures and diversities and
people like it wasn't just like i went
and painted myself
you know the garden but like the entire
the entire
when he asked me if i wanted to be body
painted it was a very intentional ask it
was i want to paint the garden of eden
on you with all your fruits and
vegetables because it's inspiring and
you do raw food and
my skin is olive and when he painted on
me he's like i can't
your the fruits and vegetables don't pop
on your skin so i have to like give i'm
going to paint you black first i'm going
to paint everything over it and i didn't
even i didn't think anything of it of
course right if you did think any if
there was any kind of like um
thought you probably wouldn't have done
it right and i think that that goes back
to what you're saying like people assume
and then um assign ill intent before
getting facts and i think some people
don't think the ill intent whether it is
ill intent or not matters some people
think even if your intent was not ill
it still um requires
um a response like that right whereas i
disagree with that even though
it was not intended to be harmful it was
intended to be art
um
i took all the posts down immediately
and i issued a public apology
right and i i was like i i honestly it
was my first wake-up call to many
different things
i issued a public apology as some people
accepted it some people didn't
in my heart i clearly meant no male
intent because if i did i mean like my
captions around it were like garden of
eden painted on my body like
it just
call me
call me naive at the time right we can
assume that that's accurate but
um what's interesting is that
well in my future days in the future
it's almost as if that public apology
didn't matter because some people hung
onto it so tight that it like resurfaced
multiple times after that
um well
so what you're saying is 100 accurate
like people are still trying to latch on
to that narrative and
controversy brings attention
um people have their own motives on why
they want to stir things up and when it
comes to blackface i think a lot of the
noise like people weren't looking at
like you said the intentions of it the
intentions was to make a mockery of a
specific race of people
and
you to me context matters and everything
you need the totality of
how we got to this point to say this is
this or this is not this and people just
wanted to run with their narratives
which was unfortunate because
i'm like as an artist you understand how
to work with color sometimes contrast is
a thing that is necessary to
hit your artistic vision but people want
to keep things very surface level just
to create more divide intention
and with the irony in all of this
is that no one wanted to talk to me
about how i felt about it because
it would kill the noise because
i would just literally call them out
about it because
there's documentaries where you can look
and see
the intentions of blackface of why why
they wanted to make people appear to be
rapists and vigilantes criminals and all
these things and
you're going to sit up here and try to
tell me
this fruit that's on a black foundation
is
promoting like
violence is promoting like comedy of a
skin tone
so were you guys already together when
you did this just friends we weren't
together when it happened we were we
were just friends
um
and did people know like like that you
guys were friends because that would
have been that would have been much more
nuanced i think i think that would have
been much more nuanced if people would
be like well what what do you think
about this and just kind of hear
different perspectives from it because
they're really that's the thing is like
so maybe someone else was going to
disagree and say that like they're they
feel triggered or hurt by even seeing it
even if there wasn't any ill intent but
like where's the nuance and just hearing
the differences and perspectives i think
is crucial a perspective that's not
being heard
i think most people don't realize that
a lot of people don't know about african
american history a lot of people don't
know about the mockery of blackface
because
you know when the whole george floyd
situation happened i'm just thinking i'm
just a local guy in houston but i have
people from germany and italy and moscow
messaging me was slavery in america
my kids are concerned about coming to
america
like they're not their skin tone is
closer to yours is it safe for us to
come so
there's this whole assumption like
everybody know what blackface is
now i've seen pictures of people go to
like frat parties and it's halloween and
they're like dressed up in a
brown skin tone because it's it's
costume night and i was like yeah that's
intent to make comedy out of a
race of people
which is polar opposite of what she was
trying to create from a visual artistic
style but
so many people in the world want to just
keep this tension because it's noise and
it's loud
but the assumption to me is that you
even though we're in america like people
around the world we all don't know about
you know the history and the the pain
points of this african-american culture
and so i just feel like the education
needed to be highlighted more in giving
people the fair chance to like learn
from their mistakes
um
whether it's ill intention or not um
intentional at all like if we're going
to unite in any form of way
we have to educate reform and move
forward with purpose and having a
forgiving heart and doing so right 100
and i think the approach to how someone
would want if someone felt compelled to
respond to like your choice to do that
like it could have been drastically
different i'm sure there were some very
like kind people responding i don't know
let me know but like responding to like
hey i'm not sure this was the best
idea have you considered this have you
thought about how this some people would
perceive this type of thing as opposed
to like
wow you're a horrible person i can't
believe you would at the time
no because the current climate climate
was so different the current social
climate was so different back six seven
eight years ago it was what ten i don't
know ten six to eight years ago whenever
it happened
it wasn't
it's not like today where everything is
cancelled culture everybody's trying to
shame somebody everybody so how was it
different like to for that experience
for you then do you think compared to
what it would be it happened like from
what i remember
in the comment section
there was
a lot of support
and then there was
there was a lot of hate but it
the hate is always louder than those who
offer support and it seems like there's
more people really it's just small
percentage and yes and they
like so much because they're just loud
and they they rally the haters and then
what ends up happening is you end up
having to deal with
that that lineup of of
so how so how does that work in your
relationship through all the things
you've gone through whenever you are
going through like a mentally
challenging time like socially online
how is your support your mindset your
intellect emotional intellect like
handled through your experiences i know
i have my experience whenever i'm going
through something like my husband
mike is giving me the answer that i'm
like i don't really want to hear that
from you right now even though i
actually need to hear that from him
right now
i think uh so in these particular
moments where it was a lot of
controversy around race racial tension
i've always tried to be a guide for
christina just because at the time when
things were coming together with you had
like police brutality and black lives
matter and all these things that were
just coming up and being present are we
talking about
eight years ago are we talking about
today
i don't know i guess just anything we're
talking about the collection of how
everything has come
together and how
how i've managed to like support you
through these difficult times okay
that's what it sounds like to me and i
was just going to say that
it feels like when christina you were in
the i mean because even the
whole veg news situation kind of
resurfaced some things for us
and i was there
being more of like a guide and assistant
and
giving feedback on like how things may
be perceived and well i just want to say
this i'm not totally helpless you guys
oh i did not mean no i
no i'm i am a brave enough and strong
enough female to to apologize and to
stand up when i've done something wrong
and i feel like i've done that in every
case scenario where i felt like even i
could be questioned
and i've done that um
now
i think that when it goes beyond that
and people perpetuate the hate towards
you even after that and they continue to
try and destroy you or stalk you uh or
like do many more awful things that i
won't mention here and it becomes more
of a vindictive
i think at that point you realize after
having dealt with so many of these
people because i've been online since
2012 and i've ran my co-op years before
that since 2007
you realize that there's a there's a
difference between jealousy and envy and
this was really hard for me to
understand at first because like you can
meet some females and they might be like
oh i really like your hair and your body
and it turns into like a weird jealousy
thing or something but then
envy's totally different it can be that
somebody sees you
and they see your joy
and
because they're so unhappy they can't
they can't even stand looking at you
because they're so miserable themselves
and so it like sparks something within
them where it's like either they're
benefiting off of it by gaining
attention or money
uh or something off of it but it in a
very
scary way
brings them validation and happiness to
bring you misery
um
and so when you start exploring this
concept of that i'm like okay so i can
understand
uh
where people's trigger points are and
you don't just look at things on the
surface anymore you actually start
looking at the people
looking at the people who are saying the
things and you you move beyond it um and
i just wanted to say that because it's
not always black or white with with
public disgrace and public shaming it's
not always
oh she's questionable i'm gonna call her
out oftentimes if you look more into it
if you look at like the person who
started something
it's it's it's a it's a delicate
situation oh no for sure there's
actually this woman what's her name lily
singh do you guys know her on youtube
she did this wonderful instagram video
one time where she was like talking how
to rest like she was saying something
about like responding to hater comments
and she's like are negative comments and
she's like look the reality is is that
you will never
be criticized by someone who is doing
more than you and i was like whoa
it's so
true because literally like if you're
like working on your own life you're
building your success both internally
and outwardly whether that's you know
emotionally or just like your success
that whatever success looks like for you
you're so busy you don't have time to
criticize others like literally you're
doing your own thing you're literally
you're you're like you know you're like
i disagree with what this person's doing
i disagree with the way that they're
doing that i'm gonna do it my own way
i'm going to put out into the world what
what i believe what i believe is going
to help the world what i believe is
going to make a positive impact instead
of focusing on someone else's choices
and how they're living and using their
name to you know to to get um
attraction to get get more attention
all in the name of well i just have to i
have to um help those help people who
follow them know how wrong they are when
really you don't have to do that you
could go and just say with your own um
possibility for success to share what
you really believe in and do your own
thing i honestly i think that that
statement could not be more true i
literally have zero um
i can't even comprehend a bone in my
body wanting to comment and comment
something negative on someone else's
post that i disagree with like i'll read
it and go huh i disagree with that like
the the thought of like i just don't
have time for that
nor do i want to put energy into that
yeah the slander is unnecessary yeah yes
and there's a hold on there is a
difference though i will say between
like starting a conversation for sure
my husband enjoys that he likes like oh
let's start a conversation here which
doesn't always go well online but but i
i don't i don't like to do that online
personally i'm like i don't
i don't want to be like on a screen
anymore than i already am for work and i
just find in person conversation so much
better especially when it's about
something you disagree with because you
can read body language and tone of voice
and i just think it goes so much better
but there is a difference between like
i'm just going to type something really
nasty versus like hey have you thought
about this or i think i disagree you
know what i mean so just want to clarify
that and i did i when i was bringing up
like okay cash what's your role in how
you guys support each other
in no way am i am i thinking oh you're
so helpless not at all i'm like seeing
myself in you because when i go through
something online that's like emotionally
trying um because it is harder than you
would think you know like when there's
like hundreds of thousands of people
that are just like all of a sudden
thinking about this this thing about you
because i i personally i just really
don't like to be misunderstood i i
really would rather just like let's just
explain and have an open-hearted
conversation like one-on-one as opposed
to just like the assumptions are just
really really hard for me it is really
hard for me internally to just accept
that i am going to be misunderstood by a
lot of people yeah you know most people
are not like that though most people are
gonna who are like watching your stuff
or like just love you and they just love
everything you're sharing and that is
just so beautiful because it's easy to
like not see it that way you know the
the amount of like people who are who
don't like you or whatever like it's
such a small percentage but but it is
easy because like you said they're just
louder it's easy to make it seem bigger
than it is and there are times when i'm
like trying in my i have the trying
mental challenges in my life and my
husband's like
ellen
get over it
he's like who cares what other people
think and i'm like how could you say
that because it's like it's so
right but it's so annoying to hear it
from someone else that's just my own
personal experience because i mean he
might he could say it in like you know a
nicer way a little bit gentler but you
know sometimes i just need to hear it
like you know what look at your life
like stop in your head with the online
games people you're never going to meet
in your life like look at your actual
life and then like yeah i really need to
hear that right now like things like
that really help me move forward to not
like dwell on like hard moments and also
to just accept like you know what some
people are going to disagree with me
certain things where i'm really not
being misunderstood on but they're gonna
just they're gonna disagree with me and
while i would rather have like a
in-person conversation to like find see
where we find common ground because you
can almost always find common ground
when you have a conversation
but that's what i would rather but just
not going to go like that with like the
types of things that we do for our work
i think that
people have forgotten the humanity in
others especially online totally right
so i love love what you're saying you
know
like this essence of bringing love to
the table even if you don't have
something in common with somebody and
talking it out and just listening
understanding where they're coming from
you don't have to believe the same
things but like i can love you
and disagree and i can listen it's like
this is how you bring love to the table
it's a skill
it's a skill to practice
but we're in a society right now where
it's like
you can only follow people that have
similar like god forbid i follow
somebody on instagram who's not vegan
i've actually had people message me and
say i can't believe you follow this
person don't you see what they just did
unfollow them immediately i get that all
the time and i all the time i i just
i don't even pay attention to it anymore
i don't like that because i i don't want
to live in an echo chamber i like to
hear dissenting opinions on all
different kinds of things because it
helps me to either solidify what i
believe even further and stronger
because i know what the other side is is
what their views are or it helps me to
possibly shift my mind or even if i
don't shift my mind to just see where
they're coming from and try to relate
because i don't think it's helpful to
assign ill intent exactly not something
you were talking about yeah if you want
to expand more yeah well
and i definitely like what you're saying
as well we it's so easy to get trapped
in to curating your social media
platform to
all of your likes
and i don't mean likes as in what you're
liking pictures but your interests
because soon as there's opposition in
your viewpoint there's like
there's a breach 100 and you're
uncomfortable now because it doesn't
follow the the flow of your timeline and
it's like okay
report unfollow block don't want to see
that and what that does is reinforce
beliefs
that this is the right way without
having a conversation with the other
side or seeing what the other side is
doing to like you said to get the common
ground if we have tunnel vision in only
one way we're so far from the middle
ground that we're unaware of what middle
ground is and i think social media
allows us to be in this false world and
forgetting like yeah it's okay to exist
with someone who doesn't have the same
views as you but if you have a peaceful
conversation
a conversation with compassion to
understand and hear them out we actually
can grow through this and have maturity
and development
and that's something that's missing a
lot because it's uncomfortable but
that's where the growth is like that's
really where the growth absolutely and
you know there sure there's going to be
some people who do have an ill intent
but to assign everyone as to have ill
intentions if you disagree with them i
think is a huge disservice to like our
mental growth yeah and understanding
because i think mass majority do not
have ill intent yeah in what they're
what they believe one thing that i was
always taught is to try to give
try to observe positive intentions
before i jump to the
conclusion of it being ill intentions
and so
i was taught that okay
if this happens like if someone comes in
one day and they're frustrated and then
they just happen to outlash
something at me
i need to ask myself maybe i'm having a
bad day maybe it's not me
but if this becomes a repeated behavior
and this is me having positive
intentions like saying like there's
outside factors that could be affecting
them that's causing them to like lash
out at me but if this becomes a repeated
behavior now you have a historical
record of like hey
you need to address this the way you're
like presenting yourself online with
social media or in the workplace or in
your relationship
it's it creates this opportunity for
positive feedback or specific feedback
where people can just say it and that's
kind of like something we did in our
relationship where it's like
i appreciate you for taking the time out
and seeing something that i was unaware
of because when we get in these like
ruts of frustration or misery we don't
really see it someone has to point it
out to us
100
and a lot of people in life really need
that person in their life
because if no one points it out you're
just in this cycle you're in this cycle
and you you can see that that it's
apparent in a lot of people's lives
because the way how social media is so
divisive
you know so that's why ill intention i
like that you brought that back up again
we really need to not jump so quick to
assuming that the intention was ill and
try to understand each other with
compassion and i think that even goes as
far as to the people who are commenting
on your page because i'm uh there's a
couple things here like when people are
consistently commenting like nasty
things to you or making videos that are
just outright nasty not like it not like
i'm not talking someone that's like i
disagree with this person and i'm going
to say why when it's just like a
intentional
nastiness like there's literally no
positive
videos where they like zoom in on your
face picking apart your face right and
just like awful tight it's a basically a
total click bait for money and attention
yeah and i mean for those types you just
know i honestly just feel bad for them
like that they're spending their energy
looking at my face that close that
they're literally spending their
precious energy and their time in that
way and that's not to say like i do
believe that
most that these people are generally
believe in their cause but i just don't
think it's a helpful nor beneficial
way to enhance their life or anyone's
life but aside from from that we can
even take like what you were talking
about people in person if they might say
lashing out on you
and you think well maybe they had a hard
day i think you can also look at that in
the comments as well you know sometimes
people might be responding to something
really harshly and you're like whoa
where did that come from or like accuse
you of something or name call and stuff
and it's easy to just um
just be like to just take it internally
instead of realizing like hey maybe they
were having a hard day because there are
times most of the time i don't give an
energy or respond
or i it depends on the type of message
if it's like a purposeful um no
beneficial nasty comment intentionally
um i i block move on type of thing you
know better for both of us to not be
spending energy in that way but if
sometimes every once in awhile i'm like
you know what i have the time right now
i might send a message back and there's
been a couple times where i'll send a
message back and realize the person
responds with like calmness and
apologetic like energy like oh man i'm
sorry i've just had a hard day like
literally that's happened multiple times
yeah and you realize there's just so
much more nuance to the discussion than
just black everything being so black and
white yeah the
i'd like to say the dynamic range of
the scope of conversations like what
you're describing is very like pivotal
and critical because like you said it
could either go left where it's just
completely vulgar and uncalled for
commentary in in the comment section
or it could be like hey let's i'm gonna
give you a chance to like clear this up
i'm gonna hear you out and let's see if
we can connect and move forward and
still be able to like coexist and
you really have to have the mindset to
differentiate between the two because
you don't want to take it internally and
then it's just sitting with you the rest
of the day
they probably moved on they're at a
happy hour like you know don't let that
energy just weigh on you totally let it
go move forward clear your head you know
you have a lot more people especially
like you and christina you have a lot of
people that appreciate the work that you
do
and they're
finding you as leaders in this community
to really like hone your voice and stand
true to what your calling is you know
yeah and what kind of world are we even
living in right now having this
conversation about people commenting
things like i didn't grow up obviously
neither of us grew up in that world like
before smartphones i can't even imagine
what kids are going through
experiencing like social media at such a
young age i mean honestly with like your
developing brain and everything
is just insane like just because really
like we have gotten into a place where
people say things it would never say in
real life and that's something that's
like so pivotal to
realize um
and take take take at heart you know
when you're getting any kind of message
because whether they've had a hard day
or it's just because there's that um
an anomaly from
no not showing your face like things
that you know people say really like if
you if you came up to me in real life
like what would you really say yeah we'd
likely have a really polite conversation
and enjoy ourselves together i've had
that happen so many times where i've i
mean even back when i was running the
co-op
i would have people come and buy a box
of produce from me
and they would tell me how much i've
changed their lives they'd love me
they'd hug me they take a picture with
me
one week later it turned into like a
trash
i met christina and she was so awful and
so rude and she only gave me a hug but
she didn't ask me about my life story
and this and this and like it's almost
as if
you can't there's you can't be perfect
you can't do everything right you can
only meet people where they're at
and you're right i think that we are
living in a society now where it's like
social media has
exacerbated um
this idea of i must be loved and
accepted by everybody and people are so
deathly afraid of the judgments and
criticisms of others which is why we're
now having this conversation like what's
happening in the comments section but
the truth is it doesn't matter does it
serve my purpose
am i able to still move forward and
share
what i feel will make this world be a
better place and what will actually make
a difference yeah and this applies to
not even just online social media but in
real life that you will never ever get
everyone to see things the way that get
everyone to see things the way that you
see life you know not everyone is going
to understand you you're going to have
people who see you in a way that you
don't like you're not going to get
everyone ever to just like you it's just
impossible yeah unless you're super
human and you just want people that
everybody likes which does happen
andrew's actually kind of like that yeah
in person if you're that person i need
the secret
[Music]
yeah like you just never like we're all
we're all gonna think see things in a
different way it's like a really good
thing to understand that like no matter
how something seems so common sense to
you there's gonna be at least some
people that just don't see it the way
that you do and that's okay yeah you
have to be okay with that and
knowing that one thing that i found
liberating for me is being okay with
that
but also that allows my tribe of people
who identify with me like they see me
for who i am and they can come find me
because if i'm like playing the fence of
trying to cater to too many different
social groups or
just to appease people
[Music]
you get lost in finding your identity
and your truth is really going to help
you find like your niche your community
people that help you thrive and feel
uplifted to go out in the world and like
have a positive
cause in in society so that's highly
important to me totally i mean we could
go on and on about this topic but let's
get into a little bit of like another
specific
of you know the call out culture type of
thing that you've gone through and let's
just like dive into it a little bit more
yeah
where shall we start
um i think uh if you want to pick back
pick up with the vegas let's just just
hit veg news story thank you let's do
this
but before you do i think you should
also clarify like how that situation
even came about because
you know you i know because i'm with you
like nothing happened that you did it it
appeared one morning and everybody had
whiplash whoa what did she do
um
so
essentially
what happened and i think it turned into
this whole social media storm was
veg news runs these influencer awards
every year right and they pick a bunch
of influencers or creators in every
category and they nominate them so that
they will share
their stuff on social media it helps
their platform to grow and it also
honors
vegan creators every single year i'm
nominated i've never had any complaints
up until
this year which
the
the cultural climate in january february
was all about calling everybody out on
what they'd been doing wrong and it just
it was all about cancelling people in
january february march even
and i just remember
one really late night or morning i was
scrolling on instagram and veg news had
just posted
uh thank you to everybody who spoke up
we are removing fully raw christina from
the ballot for
behaviors of discrimination
racism
uh
neo-nazism and anti-semitic beliefs and
we're also removing this other person
who has been accused of
wha what was it like pedophilia and
sexual abuse of like children or
something i don't you have women but
lumping you in together yeah and they
threw me under the bus with him
i think something that's really
important
it wasn't it it was they yes the
organization but i think what people
need to realize it only took one person
to make that call 100 well and it
started with one person
who convinced 40 people to complain
about me and instead of veg news
reaching out to me and asking me after a
decade of having a strong relationship
with them uh is this true christina can
you confirm that all of this is no
instead they were so afraid of being
canceled themselves
that they believed these 40 complaints
or whatever people who had
literally aimed me as a target and had
how do you say this they selected me out
basically
um and it started with one woman's
youtube video followed by another one
woman's assumption turned into this
ripple effect and they wanted me
dismantled
and it wasn't for something that i had
done even this year last year the year
before that it was things that were done
six eight years ago
and it was an accumulation of everything
that could have been considered
a wrongdoing right in my entire online
when it's really just assumption not
understanding intent all that and i
think you can speak to a greater most
important thing with this this whole
conversation is that it's not that the
people at veg news were like oh gosh we
really don't want to work with christina
because she really is this way no they
were just afraid of being canceled
themselves exactly something oh my god
well here's the the worst part about all
of this is that
i woke up to a social media storm
receiving an incredible amount of
awful hatred the next morning and i'm
like oh it's because they're like a news
outlet and they're gonna be saying this
is what you're like this is not just
some random person in the comments
people believe them to be credible veg
news their magazine is in every whole
foods across the country and here they
are they've just called fully raw
christina not only a racist but a
neo-nazi they threw me under the bus
with a sexual offender like i mean could
it really get any worse and i'm sitting
there thinking to myself this
this is bad
so bad so what ended up happening is a
few days went by and i was forced to
make a public statement that i'm i mean
by forced i mean my own integrity would
not just let this one go under the rug
right at some point some things get so
bad we were like you know what i'm not
going to say anything
this one hurt so bad on so many
different levels
i
i got on alive and i spoke my truth i
said i am not a racist i am not a
neo-nazi i don't have anti-semitic
beliefs i have zero sexual predator like
i had to like set the record straight
because i actually had people messaging
me asking if i was these things and that
they were confused where it was coming
from now at the time i didn't understand
where it came from but after legal got
involved i understood all of it
and um i am to this day very sorry that
veg news chose not to issue a public
apology i think they were afraid to do
that
um and you know what it doesn't matter
because i spoke my own truth i took two
weeks off social media i gathered myself
i took care of myself the best way i
knew how and my mental health and i came
out and i shared my truth and i received
far more support than i did hate after
that
and um in a way it was it was a nice
clearing for me am i still recovering
from it absolutely i've you know i it
took me months to bounce back after that
i couldn't have conversations with
people in real life without
feeling
so much judgment from people right and
um
yeah those these situations are not easy
but like it's not like i woke up one day
and it was just like i'd done something
wrong it was like every ghost in my
closet
a couple of people decided to like
take out of the closet or i mean what i
don't want to say in the closet because
these are things that were out in the
open that i already publicly apologized
for well and all right so really like
these publicly apologize let's just take
like for the record here like what did
what have you ever actually done wrong
i mean it's like i'm apologizing
for
maybe even being doing something
questionable or just something that
someone else takes that that they were
upset by that they personally upset by
and like i mean that's beautiful your
humility and stuff but like let's just
like be clear here like someone thinking
well where is this neo-nazi thing coming
from no
don't even entertain it this is just
nonsense
i think where it really got hurtful for
me
is
when
there were members of the community and
especially this group who was targeting
me who commented awful things on my
pictures that i was saying you know i
was just dating cash to prove that i
wasn't a racist and that deep down i was
a racist and i was doing all this to
like
somehow put up a front i'll i'll speak
on that
because i feel like i'm very qualified
to do so like we're talking about
racial issues
african-american issues
and like
you know people are trying to label you
racist and you're just dating me because
it's convenient and it's like
before all of
before everything was mainstream
with um
you know black lives being slaughtered
in the streets
and all that like i was already
interested in you he was interested in
me we just had hurdles to overcome
and so people try to create these
narratives once again to fit something
that's convenient for their talking
point and it's like no i i had ties with
christina before the controversy
and
no one and two things i want to say
because i think people really need to
understand and see this fully
transparent
the trouble
that christina had to go through
veg news it only took one person who was
running their account to make that call
on whether she should be removed based
on the information that was provided
which is unfortunate because with
media outlets of this magnitude
we put the public puts trust in
information being at least give me like
give me 90 valid
but if you're not even validating your
source like at least have the decency to
reach out to me and ask and then the
second thing i want to say is that if
you didn't have sources and you're
thinking about removing her i'm like the
most qualified source to ask yeah and
nobody throughout this entire veg news
fiasco
reached out to cash to ask how he was
feeling about any of them which is
absolutely bizarre because if you're
just talking about let's just even take
the people who are accusing you this who
are saying that that oh you're you're
just using him i mean they're literally
they're that they're thinking that
they're doing something that's trying to
help the black community right when
really they are insinuating that you're
not smart enough to know if your own
girlfriend is using you which is just
so horrendous right horrendous to
further elaborate on that because i i
just really feel like this is
definitely needs to be heard across a
lot of ears in america or just in the
world
um
the whole civil rights slavery like
we're talking about 1950 1960
and it's like y'all you know these
companies and outlets and organizations
and people is like you don't think i
don't have family members that
integrated schools you know first
african americans that integrated high
schools middle schools
they're still alive you don't think i
know what racism looks like i got
stories from
first
account witnesses who've experienced it
from coaches and teachers family members
so i was like if you needed a source you
could have had the courage to
speak to me about that and if we're
gonna talk about like black voices
matter you definitely just silence mine
so now you're like hypocritical at the
same time because you're trying to cover
your own mistakes but silence me at the
same time when all this could have been
avoided if we would have had
uncomfortable conversations from the
beginning instead of just being afraid
of the peer pressure of the canceled
call out culture but you know it takes
time and energy for people to do that
but you got to have the courage to admit
like i'm thinking about removing you can
i talk to cash
about this absolutely and and just um
the the fact that they're not seeing the
hypocrisy with not being willing to
discuss with you just completely it's
just insane to me yeah i for me
i felt offended and i had to express
that to christina because it weighed on
me as well and it's like you guys are
trying to label someone that i care care
deeply about been around my family is
assisting my family to get
reverse their diabetes um help my mom
reverse her arthritis
but she's racist
i mean do the math it doesn't add up to
me
it doesn't it's just common sense
honestly yeah so this person christina
like she cares deeply about people she
has so many people that come to her
retreats of all nationalities we don't
put a filter on who can show up like
everyone that comes in to her retreats
or co-op they experience love and it's
genuine and it's like i'm i'm being
present
for you i know i have an image a brand
but it was built off because i cared
about i was out really focused of the
community who needed someone like me
i think hypocrisy thank you babe that
was very smart
very sweet um
i think the hypocrisy runs
i think even if fed news had said can
you explain one thing to me
it was almost as if i mean just keep in
mind i've had a relationship with them
ever since i used to sell their
magazines at my co-op back in texas yeah
that's how i know it really wasn't about
that i was just worried about being
afraid of being so people and if they
had known anything about me
just for anybody who's wondering well
how did all these things just magically
pop into the air why were you accused of
so many things at once it's like
well
it was almost as if people who disliked
me decided they really didn't like me
and since it was a general time of
people being canceled at the time we
don't like christina i think let's just
like throw her under the bus because of
xyz
and
i think as well when people started
accusing me of having anti-semitic
beliefs or being a neo-nazi i'm like do
i need to explain to you i was raised by
two immigrant parents
my mother is lebanese my whole family is
lebanese
i mean it's like but see the thing is
that defending yourself even in that way
makes you look more guilty right well no
they just don't they like you're just
not allowed to do that you're not
allowed to do that so it's it's like you
gracefully take the heat and you
apologize which is what i did and it
you're always going to have people who
still hate you and you think that you've
like you're carrying a scarlet letter to
a certain degree but i don't know i'm
i'm kind of in the camp where i'll
apologize if i really believe i did
something wrong
right personally there's a way to
navigate it and you have to i always say
you have to know yourself better than
the people that's judging you right and
i feel like i did it exactly what was
good like appropriate for me at the time
i don't know it's amazing amazing you're
so humble it's amazing i feel like i did
what was was best for me and
something that i'm working on is no
longer carrying a scarlet letter
because that is not something i choose
to carry or whatever wasn't my intent to
carry
right other people don't get to decide
for us in that way we get to decide
right how we carry ourselves and how we
show up in the world and this goes down
to
like when andrew's telling me like who
cares what people think about you why
are you letting this affect your actual
real life you know like because that's
like us like you're saying the scarlet
letter like like carrying other people's
burdens of their own
lack of common sense really because what
you're saying is like you're like i'm a
good source come talk to me
and also just the knowing the history of
just your life and your relationships
just it's gotten to a point now where
names are being thrown around in such a
watered down way it's muddling down
watering the word that it it loses its
meaning and it actually provides
protection for the real white
supremacists they're the ones who
actually are these things because it
puts all these huge huge amount of
people in that camp because the moment
you disagree with someone the moment i
don't like what you're saying you're
this but like hold on like i know that
these people don't actually believe this
they're just saying it because it's
what's the word we were like trying to
come up we couldn't remember last night
um we're blanking again i know oh i
really
i know this oh a virtue signature virtue
yeah yes because i know like because
this comes down and since you're talking
about the george floyd like when
everything was happening i had just
given birth to cofax a week and a half
prior
i was in babyland i was in just like not
really on social media at all if i was
it was for like you know maybe half
maybe two minutes you know yeah and then
i'm just starting to see like
i'm just getting a massive onslaught of
um comments for not
saying speaking in the way online
publicly about george floyd that most
people were talking yeah and um i'm
seeing over and over again just like
white supremacists neo-nazi all these
all these labels and then in my head i'm
like i know these people don't really
believe this like i know that they like
let's give let's give some
what's the word were you just benefit of
the doubt yeah um yeah and i'm also i'm
just type of person where i'm i'm gonna
speak when i have all the details i'm
not the type of person to just jump to
speaking on something
when i don't like know much about it
because really anytime anything huge
comes out in the news that's really
meaningful and important i i inevitably
get a lot of people and i'm sure you two
messaging why aren't you talking about
this you need to be talking about this
you need to be talking about
mauna kea you need to be talking about
australian fires you need to be talking
about every little thing and
not saying those things are little let
me just be clear i've probably misspoken
that way but um yeah it's just one of
those things i'm going to be true to
myself and i'm going to speak when it
when it's very genuine
and what i really want to say so that
just reminds me of that yeah and
i so i get what you i just want to add
to what you're saying like world events
matter
but when the event is very controversial
and gray
we need sometimes we need like personal
personally some people need more time to
just assess what's happening and when
you're speaking about the george floyd
like we all knew that a man being
murdered in the street is not right
everyone knew that i don't know a single
person that that thought what happened
to him was okay not a single person yeah
everyone knew like okay that's wrong
maybe some people were quick with their
assessment and saying like let's go take
this to the next level maybe some people
are like okay what happened prior maybe
some people were just trying to figure
out
where did what was the combination of
people and place time location to make
this thing happen where a man lost his
life
um
but in in the social media online world
is like you're not moving fast enough
with this conversation and i got an
issue with it and it's like just give me
time to just process we all like that
was a traumatic experience for the world
we all ex process and experience trauma
in different ways so to jump to an
assumption like yeah you should be able
to move through this like some people
can't even watch uh
two action films is too violent because
it's like blood and
stuff it's a good thing that you don't
do that i can't make it through them i
mean
people their body their emotional state
gets triggered by stuff like that and we
saw this like this was not scripted this
was not acted this was just live
life happening was something we thought
we would never see
and i think for this world it's a great
case study to show like yeah we all
experience trauma differently and we all
move through it differently and there's
also what we were kind of talking about
last night about
how um being afraid to say the wrong
thing
um
i think that really that actually ties
into what what something i wanted to
read a quote
a statistic that i was reading about
there's a new cato national survey that
finds that self-censorship is on the
rise in the united states nearly
two-thirds 62 percent of americans say
that the political climate these days
prevents them from saying things that
they believe because others might find
them offensive so when it comes to this
experience i i totally saw this all
across the board from so many people
being like wait this isn't the right way
to say this you need to say it this way
and so many things to just having grace
with people and understanding that this
was a huge life effect life
yeah a news event and there's anyways
yeah
yeah i think
you know with people kind of like
censoring them well i don't want to use
the word censoring
but i think people evaluating their
words more carefully
um you can still speak your truth and
not be censored
but i think you have to understand how
is it going to come across
and
because i don't i don't feel like people
need to be censored but they just need
to really think it through like how is
it about my tone is it about the pacing
of my comments that is going to offend
someone is it my
my mannerisms
there's so many things that trigger
people yeah and the reality is like we
said before like you're literally you're
not going to be able to get everybody to
understand you there are going to be
people who misunderstand you so i do
find a lot of inspiration from people
who just speak exactly what they want to
say and know that you know what some
people are not gonna understand me and
gonna say it differently it's not for
everybody and i find that super
inspiring and that's actually something
i wanna continue doing more on this
podcast that's why i started one of the
reasons why i started the podcast
because i'm the type of person that like
instagram captions just hold me up i'm
saying that i'm like oh i can't fit it
all in this one little caption and i
want to make sure i'm not misunderstood
i want to make sure i'm covering every
aspect of things because i want to
acknowledge all the different people's
perspectives and experiences and you
know not make anyone feel like when
they're looking at well you didn't speak
on to me what about what this pers this
thought you know yeah and so i like
podcasts being like a long form able to
kind of cover so much more depth it's uh
thought provoking where it's just making
you think past
those your your own social constructs
you know so i think thought provoking is
really
a good label for it for sure and i think
podcasts are actually like
not hit their peak yet they're just
majorly on the rise it's a new way to
listen to long conversations um as
opposed to like sound bites and small
little nuggets and just really have a
more nuanced conversation and get into
that gray and that middle yeah middle
discussion yeah um i think like rounding
it out though like something an overall
theme that i think is so important for
like everyone to take away from whether
you're online or whether you're not is
just like
um
not letting how other people think about
you dictate your reality
you know absolutely and that it's a
challenge it can be it can be a
challenge
it's a skill that's something that my
husband is super good at sounds like
you're really good at that cash
and honestly look how much you like what
all you've gone through look how strong
you are christina like it's definitely
made me stronger yes um but i i would
say continuing to show up with love and
grace in every case scenario and
to continue to strive to be the best
person of yourself and if if anything
ever comes in the way of that like
really the best thing you can focus on
is focus on you
not not for that to sound selfish in any
way but it's very easy to get caught up
in
the thoughts assumptions and
in that pain of what other people are
projecting on to you but if you just
stay focused and you stay in your lane
and you're kind
and you're focused on bringing love to
the table and being a vessel of love i
truly believe that that is where the
growth happens well yeah and the growth
really does happen to your mind and your
choice because it is your choice to let
other people's opinions affect you it is
my choice when i'm like you know having
a day where i'm like oh my gosh i can't
believe all these people think these
things about me i feel so misunderstood
i wish they understood that this is what
i'm actually thinking like that is my
choice to let that ruin my day my
anyways go ahead i was gonna say for me
there's this specific moment in my life
where i had that breakthrough moment of
like
yeah i can be myself for the rest of my
life and be okay with it it was at a
pitiful pivotal time in my life where i
needed a
job because i wasn't working at the time
and i just came out of a bad
the previous job was just i just didn't
enjoy it i felt like i had to be someone
else to fit like their narrative of like
what the employee is
and i got let go from that job and i was
like you know i'm either going to work
for myself or the next job i'm going to
have like i have to be myself or this is
not going to work i went through a few
interviews and ended up talking to one
of the managers and i told them
i just said i said hey man like if i
can't be myself at this job
i can't work here like i don't i don't
want i don't want this job
and i was like man what did i just say
because like sometimes you're just like
you're in the emotional state of like i
need my freedom
more so than me trying to be logical
like i might lose a good paycheck
and
it came out so fast i was like okay
let's just see what happens yeah and
he's like because at that time i knew my
character very well and that's why i
said you have to know yourself better
than the people that's judging you
i knew myself very well so i said if if
these people accept me they're going to
get the best version of me and he was
like do you like being like this like
are you being yourself right now he was
like cool
i like it and i was like
that's like it's okay like i cause it
was that moment of like i spoke my truth
and i feel like a lot of people are
scared to speak their truth but what
happens when you speak the truth and
someone confirms that it's okay to be
that version of yourself you're free
from people's perspective of how you
should be and now it's like you have
this opportunity to really like take off
in life and just like be an impactful
player in society and i think a lot of
people need to put themselves in
positions where it's like no this is me
i need you to accept and if you don't
there's a tribe out there that's ready
to welcome me you know
absolutely that was like amazing that's
an amazing way to end it
well-rounded way to end it is there
anything else i mean that we should say
from this topic because i mean that i
mean you just said it all right there
gotta show up as an impactful player in
society well said yeah i just want to
say like ellen thanks for having us i
know thank you i am so honored to have
you guys here like and talk about this
topic i think is such a fantastic
conversation i'm sure we could go on and
on and on and just like you know trying
to figure out the the conclusion like so
where do we go from here where do we go
how do we how do we all collectively
like move to a place where we can hear
other people's
um like their stories their intentions
and like just listen more before jumping
to conclusions
in real life as well in your
relationships like i mean how many times
in our relationships in real life have
we like jumped to a conclusion thinking
someone had this intention when they
actually didn't and we should just
listen more
um i think
i think a good place to start is within
your own community of friends
because
our friends are on social media but like
what's better a better the practice is
in real life in real life situations of
like trying to provide that feedback
um and even asking people are you even
in a place to receive feedback
because sometimes the the feedback
that's in our comment section no one's
asking like hey you ready for the
slander i have for you
and i'm not saying like it needs to be
slandered but you need to sometimes you
just need to check with that person and
say like i have some things i need to
express to you
are you in a position to even hear me
out right yeah
yeah yeah that's to me that's
this that's a great area to start and
see where it leaves from there i sorry
do you have something to say i always no
continue on okay so i was gonna say
something that we we're starting to
touch on but we forgot that this is like
something we definitely want to talk
about was the online live how easy it is
to live in an echo chamber and how you
want to follow someone because you love
what they're about and you agree with
what they're saying and how easy it is
to just assume that you agree with
everything that they believe in yeah and
the moment they kind of veer off the
course you think that they should have
it's really easy for a lot of people to
just jump [ __ ] be like peace out i'm
gone unfollowing you i don't like what
you think what you think is wrong and
not only wrong but immoral
because you disagree i disagree with you
and i just think that does us a huge
disservice to our humanity and society
and our culture because you're never
going to find anyone who agrees with you
on everything from everything you know
like and we need to hear other opinions
i personally like to
listen to people and follow people who
disagree with me on certain things
because i think we did talk about that
aspect but but the importance of just
hearing everybody out and like not
assuming
that you know there's this malice behind
someone who disagrees about something
because it helps you to have a stronger
understanding of why you think the way
that you do yeah i think it's important
for anybody listening
anytime you're entering a conversation
or making a post
consider
how you can create more unity instead of
division
and i think that's important because
right now every single person without
thinking
is creating more division right it's all
about what i want and this is right this
is wrong it's like it's all about
division division division but i think
that if we just shift our perspective a
little bit and shift the way we are
coming into conversations
we can easily find a way to foster more
unity and i think that is really what we
need that's such a good point because we
really need to just like meet people
where they're at understand that people
have hurt in their life and traumas and
just try not to take things personally
and anyone who does you know hate me and
have all these you know nasty negative
things about me or even if they're just
negative and disagree like it's okay i
can let people think what they think and
at the end of the day like that's okay
yeah that's all right and it's also okay
to consider that some people might not
have the tools in their toolbox that
they need to mentally physically
emotionally handle certain things and so
the way that they are lashing out is
the only way that they know how to to
actually cope with the situation and we
can also learn from ourselves and how
can i grow how can i respond better
because that's very humbling it's easy
to just be like i got it all together
this person when really it's like no we
got our own we all got our own things
going i mean we're always gonna be
adding more tools in our toolbox yeah
like looking inward you know because
it's easy to oh that person maybe that
person's going through a hard day you
know but i also need to look into like
okay where am i at where do i need to
grow what am i absolutely you know
contributing in a in a way that needs to
grow so i always got to approach the
conversation saying how can i bring more
unity here
right
that's perfect i mean i think this is
this let's call it a wrap this is yeah
that's a great way to end i think this
is a unified table and i'm like yeah
totally ellen thank you so much of
course oh my gosh this is amazing all
right we'll see you next episode guys
thank you so much for joining
[Music]
you